[Music]
just ending in the house of commons
prime minister's questions next with me
our political editor beth rigby beth it
looks like a box office session
it really is and and the prime minister
is under huge pressure as he goes into
that chamber the bench is behind him the
mood is terrible over this alleged
christmas party and the footage that
emerged on itv
overnight and then for kia stammer this
really is his moment to pin uh boris
johnson to the wall and really really do
some damage so it's going to be a very
very lively and important prime
minister's uh promises questions for
both leaders i mean we've heard some
parties calling for the prime minister
to resign would you effect to expect
kirsten
chris bryant the chair of the public
standards committee actually told sky
slightly earlier today that he thought
the prime minister
should resign uh let's see if kierstarma
will go there he might think it's a step
too far but what he will want to do is
put forward uh the case about the prime
minister uh not telling the truth to the
public it will lead into what he did
last week about the prime minister that
breaks promises and a prime minister
that behaves like there's one rule for
him and another for everyone else let's
see what boris johnson comes up with
there's been no ministers on any of the
morning rounds will he announce an
inquiry
will he announce that people are
resigning
what is he going to do or is he just
going to bounce it into announcing new
covered rules in a way of trying to move
away from this as kierstama presses him
on it but what we're seeing is that the
effect of
this row over the party is affecting the
government's ability to communicate on
the important matter of fighting the
virus absolutely there was a cabinet
meeting yesterday chris whittie
understand gave a presentation the
numbers were not looking good there was
nervousness the prime minister i'm told
is minded to move to plan b he's worried
that if he doesn't act now he will
regret that in a month's time but what
about the messaging to the public now a
prime minister now uh taking his seat uh
so i think mr speaker will be
throwing prime minister's questions over
to him imminently
mr mcneil i don't need any help from you
this is an important message to those
people who are watching brilliant thanks
before i come to the prime minister's
questions i would like to point out that
the british sign language interpretation
of proceedings is available to watch on
the palm live tv come to prime
minister's questions little richards
[Music]
mr speaker may i
begin by saying that i understand and
share the anger
up and down the country at seeing number
10 staff
seeming to make light of lockdown
measures
and i can understand
how infuriating it must be to think that
the people who have been setting the
rules have not been following the rules
mr speaker because i was also furious to
see that clip
and mr speaker
i apologize
i apologize unreservedly for the offence
that it has caused up and down the
country and i apologize for the
impression that it gives
but i
repeat mr speaker that i have been
repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged that there was no
party
and that
and that no kovid rules were broken and
that is what i have been repeatedly
assured but i've asked
the cabinet secretary
to establish all the facts
and to report back as soon as possible
and mr speaker it goes without saying
that if those rules were broken then
there will be disciplinary action for
all those involved mr speaker this
morning i had meetings with ministerial
colleagues and others and in addition to
my duties in this house i shall have
further such meetings later today
mr speaker bins left uncollected council
tenants being forced to live in damp and
cold homes 22 million pounds lost on
providence place land deal and a 10
million pound overspend on scnd
transport contracts which were almost
awarded to labour councillors friends
today the council's external auditors
released a damn report that surprises
none of us does the prime minister agree
with me that 47 years of labour control
in samwell has done nothing to lev has
done nothing but level down my
constituency of west bromwiches and that
my constituents in west grammage
and great bar deserve
mr speaker i better
agree with my honorable friend because
the instinct of labor councillors up and
down this country is yet again to level
down rather than to level up and i i and
i encourage her constituents to install
a labour councillor a labour council
there as soon as possible a conservative
council there as soon as possible mr
speaker we now come to the leader of the
opposition kirsten
[Music]
thank you mr speaker i i heard what the
prime minister said at the beginning of
this session but frankly it raises more
questions than answers
last week i asked the prime minister was
there a christmas party in downing
street for dozens of people on december
the 18th the prime minister the
government spent the week telling the
british public there was no party
all guidance was followed completely
millions of people now think the prime
minister was taking them for fools
and that
[Applause]
mr speaker i think the right honourable
gentleman probably missed what i said uh
at the beginning but i apologize i
apologize for
uh for the impression that uh has been
given uh that staff and danny street
take this less than seriously uh i'm i'm
i'm sickened myself and furious about
that
but i repeat what i have said to him
that
that i've been repeatedly assured that
the rules that those
are not ordered in order and i apologize
right well let's just do a little less
promise
it's important
ask the cabinet secretary to investigate
exactly what happened and i i repeat
that there will be consequences for
those involved if those rules were
broken mr speaker
an internal investigation into what
happened
the situation is as clear as day
i thought last week was mr speaker i
thought last week was bad enough surely
surely the prime minister isn't now
going to start pretending that the first
he knew about this was last night surely
he's in his own house
we've all watched the video of the prime
minister's staff
including his personal spokesperson
they knew there was a party
they knew it was against the rules they
knew they couldn't admit it
and they thought it was funny
it's obvious what happened
anton decker ahead of the prime minister
on this
the prime minister has been caught
red-handed why doesn't he end the
investigation right now by just
admitting it
because mr speaker i've been repeatedly
assured that no rules were broken uh mr
speaker
and they may not i and i understand i
understand public anxiety about this and
i understand a public indignation
but that is uh but there is a risk of
doing a a great a grave injustice to
people uh who are frankly obeying the
rules mr speaker that is why the cabinet
secretary will be conducting an
investigation and that's why there will
be uh the requisite there will be the
requisite uh disciplinary action if
necessary
[Music]
this pretends that further information
has come to light give me a break
he's still taking the public for falls
on the day of the downing street party
tricia greenhall's mum phoned her
she was breathless and feverish
you might want to listen trisha followed
the rules
and didn't visit her mom listening
four days later on the day the prime
minister's staff laughed about covering
up the party
tricia's mum was admitted to hospital
trisha followed the rules
and didn't visit
trisha's mum spent christmas day in
hospital
trisha followed the rules and didn't
visit
two days later trisha's mum died
what trisha wants to know is this
why did the prime minister expect her to
accept
that the rules allowed a downing street
party
but didn't allow her to visit her dying
mother
prime minister mr speaker the first
thing to say is that in common with
everybody in this house i extend my
sympathies to uh the family of trisha
and of course i understand uh patricia
and our family and i understand the the
pain of everybody who has suffered
throughout this pandemic and i know that
he uh and i know that the implication
that he is trying to to draw that uh the
the case that he that we're now
investigating somehow should undermine
uh public confidence in the the measures
that we're taking i think that's the
point uh that he's trying to make but i
may say to him mr speaker i think it is
a great mistake to try to play politics
with this issue and i think that is i
think that is what he is doing i think
that is what he is doing and the public
the public mr speaker i will not like to
see i don't think the public do want to
see confidence in their measures in
these measures undermined and we are
taking we are taking
i think they can see the difference mr
speaker we are taking we are taking the
steps necessary to protect the public
above all mr speaker by rolling out of
the vaccinations on it and rather than
focusing on the events of a year ago mr
speaker that is what we are focusing on
and that is what i think the public will
understand
but it's not just the events of a year
ago is it we are facing a new variant we
may well be in plan b this afternoon
even the prime minister even the prime
minister must understand the damage he's
done to his credibility in enforcing the
rules now and in the future
trisha made an enormous personal
sacrifice to do the right thing to
follow the rules and help defeat the
virus that's what she was asked to do
most people were just like trisha last
christmas
no one was dreaming of a zoom christmas
turkey dinners for one
gifts exchanged at service stations
but the virus was out of control
489 people died of covid on the day of
the downing street party
so the british people put the health of
others
above themselves and followed the rules
isn't the prime minister ashamed that
his downing street couldn't do the same
my minister
mr speaker mr speaker i've i've said
what i've said about the uh the events
on december the 18th they will probably
they will be properly investigated and
mr speaker i will uh place a copy of the
uh of the cabinet secretary's report in
the in the library of the house of
commons but what people should not do is
lose focus on what we are trying to do
now rather than uh
of course we will we will deal with the
events of what may or may not have taken
place uh on the 18th of december last
year mr speaker but what i think we need
to focus on today is what we're doing to
roll out uh the vaccinations across this
country and what we're doing to protect
the public and and he is indeed right mr
speaker that we now have in the omicron
uh in the omicron variant a variant that
is spreading much faster mr speaker than
any variant that we've seen before and
that is what we need uh with great
respect to the rhino gentleman to focus
on and that is why i ask everybody to go
and get their booster jab as soon as
they're called forward
the prime minister apparently wants us
to focus on what's happening today there
were no government spokespersons on the
media this morning i see the health
sector has made it to the chamber
and that's the point mr speaker this
virus isn't defeated we're going to face
other tests where the british people may
be asked by their leaders to make
further sacrifices for the greater good
her majesty the queen sat alone when she
marked the passing of the man she'd been
married for 73 years
leadership
sacrifice
that's what gives leaders the moral
authority to lead
does the prime minister think he
has the moral authority to lead and to
ask the british people to stick to the
rules
not only that mr speaker but uh they the
labour party and the the labour leader
in particular have played politics have
played politics mr speaker throughout
throughout this pandemic
i've got to tell you what the premise is
saying because if i don't i don't know
when something is said
and i must hear the prime minister prime
minister uh yes mr speaker and if i may
say so throughout this pandemic
throughout this pandemic uh the leader
of the opposition in particular has done
nothing but play politics to try to
muddy the waters uh to confuse the
public and uh and to cause needless
confusion about the guidance uh well the
public mr speaker have not been so
confused and they have not been fooled
and they have got on with implementing
the guidance and they have got on in
particular mr speaker with showing great
commitment to the health of this country
by going forward to get vaccinated order
order prime minister climate
streeting we've had this the week before
i'm not having this every week now if
you want to be on the front bench behave
like you're meant to be the prime
minister
[Music]
mr speaker at every stage the labor
leadership and the labor right
honourable gentlemen have tried to muddy
the waters and to play politics whereas
the people of this country have not been
fooled and in particular they have come
forward to get vaccinated faster than
any other country in europe we've now
done 20 million boosters mr speaker that
is the single best thing that we can do
and i encourage everybody to keep going
and get that booster
that's so desperate and even his own
side can see it
last week the prime minister told us
there was no party now he thinks there's
something to investigate
the justice secretary thinks the police
don't investigate crimes from a year ago
well i ran the crown prosecution service
and i cannot tell him that is total
nonsense
mr speaker
westminster magistrates court right now
the cps are prosecuting over a dozen
breaches of covet restrictions last
december including those prime minister
hosted parties
they're doing their job
enforcing the law set in downing street
will the prime minister support the
police
and support the cps by handing over
everything the government knows about
partisan downing street to the
metropolitan police
[Music]
[Applause]
mr speaker of course we will do uh we
will do that and we will get on uh with
the the investigation by the cabinet
secretary and mr speaker he continually
wants to play politics with this issue
we want to get on with our job of
protecting this country during the
pandemic and mr speaker delivering the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe
fighting the drugs gangs mr speaker when
that the party opposite wants to
decriminalize class a drugs uh mr
speaker and backing our borders bill mr
speaker they have an opportunity to
focus on that tonight why not back our
borders bill mr speaker and have life
sentences for people traffickers that's
what the opposition should be doing
that's what i urge you rather than
playing politics
here
sorry
fiona bruce
yeah
as we celebrate the advent of christmas
i thank the prime minister for his
support for christians and those of
other faiths and beliefs who face
persecution across the world we here
stand with them
the government has talked about the gift
of resettlement for afghans who are
members of religious minorities of those
at risk of persecution targeted for
their beliefs
will this gift of resettlement be
available by the end of christmas
prime minister i i thank her very much
for everything that she does
particularly as a special envoy for
freedom of of religion and uh belief the
uh as she rightly says we have an afghan
uh citizens resettlement scheme uh
coming uh we've already taken fifteen
thousand uh but it's important that we
get that scheme right mr speaker and
further details including the
eligibility criteria will be announced
uh in due course uh by the home office i
don't call the leader of the snp able
[Applause]
thank you
mr speaker
we are standing on the cliff edge
of yet another challenging moment in
this pandemic
omicron cases are rising
at a rapid rate over the coming weeks
tough decisions will again have to be
made
to save lives
and protect your nhs mr speaker
trust and leadership
is a matter of life and death
downing street willfully broke the rules
and mocked the sacrifices we have all
made
shattering the public's trust
the prime minister
is responsible for losing the trust of
the people
he can no longer lead on the most
pressing issue
facing these islands the prime minister
has a duty
the only right and moral choice left to
him
it is for his
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
resignation
mr speaker i'm uh the party opposite and
indeed the other party opposite are
going to continue to play politics i am
going to get on with the job
[Music]
no dignity from a prime minister that
quite simply just doesn't get it
mr speaker people across these islands
have followed the rules even when it
meant missing friends and family
missing births missing funerals
missing the chance to be beside a loved
one in their dying moments
people have sacrificed at times to the
point of breaking while the uk
government has laughed in our faces
it is clear that this prime minister has
lost the support of the public and now
even his own benches
this is not a grin and barrett moment
this is a moment
of moral reckoning
every member
of the conservative benches must now
decide
is this the man
to lead these islands when lives are at
stake
it is clear
that this prime minister
intends to desperately cling on to power
and i have nothing left to say to a man
whose answers we simply can't trust
so mr speaker
i will hear this question whether the
front bench like it or not can i just
say i'm expecting better behavior the
public out there are questing this
parliament don't answer that question
ian blackford i think this parliament
and questioning this prime minister that
we cannot trust
it is clear that the prime minister
desperately is clinging on to power and
i've got nothing left to say to a man
who we simply cannot trust
so mr speaker it is time for members in
this house to act if he doesn't resign
then he must be removed
prime minister
mr speaker i i thank the writer of the
gentleman
uh support and thanks a vote of
his vote please
confidence but i can tell him that i am
going to get on with the job and i
believe
i believe that
that is what
is the right thing to do and i think it
is very very sad uh that when the public
need to hear clarity uh from their
officials and from politicians uh the
the the party's opposite are trying to
muddy the waters about events or
non-events of a year ago mr speaker and
that is what that is what they they're
doing today
we now have a closed question bob seeley
number five please mr speaker prime
minister
i thank my honourable friend who is an
excellent champion for for the isle of
wight and i know there is ongoing
discussion between isle of wight in the
department for leveling up about the
unique circumstances of the island
including the discussions about the
possibility of a county deal
bob sulay i thank the prime minister for
his uh response will the government
accept the findings of the independent
study that it itself commissioned this
summer into a long-term fair funding
settlement for the island the final
calculations of which are due imminently
and in doing so will he help me to right
a wrong which has been ongoing now for
the island for my constituents for some
six decades thank you prime minister
i thank my my little friend very much
you will understand it's not easy to
break down the costs that apply to the
service delivery on the island but i
know the department is carefully
considering the details of the study he
mentions i'm sure the relevant minister
will keep him updated so jeffrey donalds
thank you mr speaker in view of the harm
caused to political stability in
northern ireland onto our economy by the
northern ireland protocol
noting the lack of progress in removing
the irish sea border and recognizing
that unionist consent for the protocol
is not forthcoming
what urgent steps does the prime
minister and his government intend to
take to honor his commitment
to restore northern ireland's place
fully within the uk internal market and
to safeguard the political institutions
in northern ireland prime minister
i thank the right honourable gentleman
and he and i have uh discussed this
extensively and he knows that uh we
share a view that the protocol is not
working in the way that it needs to
in order to to guarantee the uh belfast
good friday agreement i don't believe
things need to be that way i think it
could be worked differently and uh we
want our eu friends and partners to
understand that and we will continue to
uh to work with them to get them to see
things in the way that uh people on both
sides of the rhc seed them but in the
meantime mr speaker we do not remove the
possibility of invoking article 16 to
protect trade between great britain and
northern ireland bob blackman thank you
mr speaker this week thousands of my
hindu constituents and millions
worldwide
start the birth centenary celebrations
of the birth of his holiness pramang
swami maharaj
his life was given over to people of all
caste races and religions he was of
course the inspiration behind the
worldwide well world-renowned neiston
temple and hundreds of other temples
will my right arm friend join me in
celebrating joining that celebration uh
and giving good wishes to all hindus
across the world
prime minister i thank my honourable
friend for raising uh this and i was
delighted to and i thank the hindu
community for their amazing contribution
to this country i was delighted to visit
new zealand temple last month and uh to
hear about all they've done during the
pandemic and i wish everybody in that
community and all those celebrating all
the very best christian authors thank
you mr speaker
the chaos of this government is a
distraction from the serious decisions
it should be taking
we all know that the chinese government
denies basic human rights to china's
minority religious communities the
repression of the predominantly muslim
uighur population in xinjiang has been
condemned as an act of genocide
in the face of these abuses president
biden has decided u.s diplomats will
boycott the beijing olympics new zealand
and australia have followed suit
it's international human rights day on
friday so will the prime minister raise
his eyes from his chaos and commit the
uk to joining the diplomatic boycott or
does his desperation for trade deals
trump human rights
no mr speaker because we make all those
points regularly to the chinese and i
did indeed i did to president xi when i
talked to him uh recently as i've said
before we do not support uh sporting
boycotts but there are no plans for
ministers a sudden no plans for
ministers uh to attend the winter
olympics that's caroline jones thank you
mr speaker mr speaker many of my
constituents in sleep for the north
haikum are struggling to access an nhs
dentist leading to pain and suffering in
particular for children military
families and veterans my right
honourable friend has invested a record
amount of money in the nhs does he agree
with me that some of this money must be
used to level up dental care provision
does he share my surprise that there is
no dental school in the east midlands
and will he back my campaign for dental
school in lincolnshire prime minister uh
mr speaker i i know that a health
education england are working
extensively in lincolnshire to improve
the recruitment and
retention of dentists i understand that
they agree with her about the uneven
distribution of dental schools
throughout the country and i'm sure as
they consider their next steps they
would have heard her appeal very careful
thank you mr speaker
storm aarwin left thousands of people
in bear park ludworth sheriban and
waterhouses without heating or
electricity yet it took five days for a
ministerial statement to be made and a
week to send in the army my constituents
weren't just left without power they
were left without a government that
cares
can the prime minister look me in the
eye and honestly see that he did
everything he could as soon as he could
to help the people of durham
prime minister yes i can mr speaker and
i can tell her that i i was in contact
with uh representatives of the local
authorities of the army uh of uh
northern power grid and and others uh to
uh see what more we could do to assist
them in restoring power
and i i sympathize very much with the
families who uh who lost power for an
unconscionably long period mr speaker
and uh the house would have heard the
explanation of the of the various
electricity companies about why that was
so we must learn the lessons from storms
irwin and barra and make sure nothing
like that happens again
mr speaker i know we'll all agree that
our vaccination program has been a
tremendous success
vaccinations are the front line of
defense against all variants of kovid
and the booster jab is a vital component
of this but in rural areas like mine our
booster centers are often few and very
far between and two-thirds of
house-bound people those perhaps most
vulnerable most susceptible and most in
need haven't yet received their booster
so can i ask
my uh right on friend what steps the
government's taking to ensure more
centers are available particularly in
rural areas and would he ask the health
sector to meet me
with some urgency to ensure my
constituents can get their boosters and
stay protected this winter
yes mr speaker amongst the heroes of the
vaccine relate are of course pharmacists
as he as he rightly says up and down the
country uh and we have 1500 community
pharmacies uh vaccine vaccinating uh
people near where they where they live
uh i i know that uh the nhs are
considering the need to support but more
pop-up uh clinics where there's a need
i'm happy to arrange a meeting uh with
him in the vaccines uh minister to
discuss this further catherine west
[Music]
thank you mr speaker will the prime
minister tell the house whether there
was a party in downing street on the
13th of november
prime minister
mr speaker no but i'm sure that and
whatever happened the guidance was
followed and the rules were followed at
all times
dr luke evans
thank you mr speaker
thank you mr speaker we know the booster
vaccines are essential in our fight
against covid
speaking to clinical colleagues one of
the biggest hindrances is the 15 minutes
people have to wait post pfizer if we
could reduce that or take that away it
could release thousands of hours of
clinicians time so will the prime
minister ask the mhra and the jcbi to
look to see if it is safe to do so
particularly for those people receiving
their third pfizer booster
prime minister uh my honourable friend
makes a very good point and i can tell
him that we are in the process of
reviewing uh the the waiting the
50-minute waiting requirement uh for uh
for both uh booster doses and we
continue to be guided by the jcbi and
the mhra
katherine smith
thank you mr speaker
my constituents are having to resort to
diy dentistry including performing diy
dentistry on their own children
money not anything has been allocated to
nhs dentistry so can the prime minister
explain why my constituents cannot
access an nhs dentist
prime minister for funding
i i thank her but uh we're putting
record funding into uh nh into the nhs
including uh into nhs dentistry and uh
if she'd like to write to me with uh
uh with the cases that she's uh that she
mentions i'd be happy to take it up with
the secretary of state for health
thank you mr speaker on many occasions
the prime minister has spoken i know to
primary age children about careers and
the opportunities that are ahead of them
does my right honourable friend agree
with me that every child should have the
chance to meet adults from different
professions different backgrounds uh to
be inspired for the future and this this
could play a major part in delivering
the leveling up agenda prime minister
yes mr speaker and i thank my honourable
friend and uh it's absolutely true that
throughout our career strategy uh we've
invested so far two million pounds to
support uh career related learning in uh
primary schools and as anybody in this
house will know uh that you get the most
extraordinary questions from primary
schools uh children and they are often
very very ambitious for their futures
jack drove me
mr speaker jane wrote from erdington her
father vince died of covid
five days later her sister died of covid
she is devastated and appalled at recent
revelations as to what has gone on in
downing street she asked this question
of the prime minister
does trust
in british politics matter
yes it does mr speaker and that's why
it's so absolutely vital uh that of
course we should get to the bottom of
whatever may or may not have taken place
on the 18th of december last year but we
need to focus on what's happening this
year mr speaker and i urge her and
everybody else to get their booster jab
and to look after themselves
mr speaker at the moment
indecent exposure or flashing
is illegal offline but not online
i really welcome my right honourable
friend support for that to change when
he spoke to the liaison committee in
november will he support
outlawing cyber flashing and other forms
of sexual image abuse online in the
forthcoming online safety bill when it
comes to this house
i think i thank my right honourable
friend and uh she she's right to draw
attention to uh that uh phenomenon of
cyber flashing and uh it is one of the
issues that is being addressed uh by my
normal friend in the online harms build
john mcnulty
yeah
thank you mr speaker
last year i asked the prime minister
what progress had been made delivering
his pledge to buy 4 000 zebs by 2024.
the budget and the spending review
confirmed the uk government planned
investment will not reach that target as
vice chair of the bus
coach and appg let me tell the prime
minister bus manufacturers have no
orders from his zebra scheme production
lines in falcor balamina and scarborough
desperate to start orders and deserve
better than this by minister why is your
government failing to deliver these
orders and that pledge
mr speaker we're absolutely committed to
delivering four thousand zero emission
buses and we're also committed to
supporting a uk uh bus manufacturing
election coming from duncan smith mr
speaker the prime minister has already
been asked about the winter olympics
but listening to his answer i have to
say sadly i think it is not at all
strong enough
may i support the request that the uk
government now acts against this
dictatorial brutal chinese regime that
is
persecuting everybody from christians
through to tibetans and
terrorizing the uyghurs with the british
government follow suit to the americans
the australians even the lithuanians and
please please i beg of him give a lead
for human rights and make a diplomatic
boycott of these olympic games hi
minister
mr speaker is clear from what i said uh
earlier on uh that the the government uh
has no hesitation in raising uh these
issues with china as i did with
president xi uh the last time i talked
to him uh and there will be there will
be effectively a uh diplomatic boycott
of the uh there will be a diplomatic
boycott of the uh of the winter olympics
in beijing no ministers are expected to
attend what i think the house
and and no officials mr speaker but what
i can tell the house is that uh i do not
think that sporting boycotts are
sensible that remains the policy of the
government
the prime minister will be aware of the
recent national audit office report on
bounce-back loans and eye-watering
levels of fraud and criminality and
covered
in the interest of the taxpayer will the
prime minister initiate a great british
bounce-back fraud squad to recover this
public money and prosecute where
appropriate even if the crime was
committed more than a year ago
prime minister
mr speaker of course we will take action
against anybody who's defrauded uh
any of the covered loans bounce back
clones or or otherwise
mr speaker there are media reports of a
cabinet meeting and press conference
this afternoon to initiate caved winter
plan b without reference to this house
covet passes will not increase uptake of
the vaccine but will create a segregated
society
is my right honourable friend the prime
minister aware that very few will be
convinced by this diversionary tactic
mr speaker
no no decisions uh will be taken without
consulting the cabinet
you need to get your dreams
thank you very much mr speaker
this country is angry and understandably
so
last christmas while we were in lockdown
millions of people were unable to be
with their families
thousands of people waved through their
care home windows at loved ones wishing
them a merry christmas from the side of
the road
people died
without that last touch
from their daughters their sons
their
wives working in intensive care
i wept behind my mask
as
three children talking to their dying
mother on an ipad
begged her to wake up
countless children now growing up
without parents
while parties were held
at number 10.
mr speaker this is disgraceful
this is an insult to everyone
who followed the rules
it is an insult to everyone who wasn't
allowed to say
their final goodbye
this happened on the prime minister's
watch so my question
my question is very simple
how does the prime minister
sleep
at night
[Applause]
mr speaker i want to say first of all uh
i want to repeat what i've said earlier
on about uh
what happened last year a year ago but
or what may not have happened but i want
to say i want to say this i share and
understand
her grief and her feelings i thank her
for her service in the nhs and uh mr
speaker i know how much this country has
been through and i know how difficult it
has been through and and if you ask me
uh how i sleep at night with the answer
is of course i take full responsibility
and personal responsibility for
everything that this government has done
but i must say to you mr speaker and i
say to the house
the way forward for this house for this
country now is to focus on the position
we are in and
above all to get our vaccinations as
fast as we possibly can we're in a much
better position this year than we were
last year and that is thanks to the
vaccination rollout and i urge every
member of this house to join that
campaign and that great british
vaccination effort
there's lots of points of order i'll
take the leader of the smp
thank you mr speaker and i have informed
the prime minister that i would be
making a point of order i was informed
by the
government front bench that he had to go
my goodness i think those of us in this
side of the house absolutely agree that
he has to go he has to go as prime
minister mr speaker
people throughout these islands have
been watching this debate today people
feel revolution
at the stories of the mayor's in
particular the video last night what is
worst prime minister
what is worse mr speaker
is that there are now authoritative
reports of not just one
not just two
but three different downing street
parties during lockdown last christmas
including one
one mr speaker in the prime minister's
flat
what do we have to do on this side of
the house to make sure that the prime
minister takes responsibilities for his
breach of trust for the breach of covert
regulations and he does the right thing
on behalf of all the people of all these
islands and he resigns and he resigns
now
[Applause]
i think i made that decision
no i know you're not and it's not to me
obviously
can i just say it is a very tense moment
for the house and i just want to try and
calm it down what i want to say is that
we can't continue a debate
after after it's already gone on what i
would say is i am not aware of any media
attention but i can also say it is not
for me to rule on something that happens
in downing street what i would say is
you've got it on the record and i think
we're going to leave it at that
point
of our
alberta costa thank you mr speaker the
committee on standards has issued its
fourth report of this session which
makes a number of proposals and
recommendations
some open for consultation as one of the
longer standing mp members of the
committee some colleagues in this house
cross party have approached me seeking
we're going to leave prime minister's
questions there a very fiery session
indeed you're going to hear from our
political editor in a moment but first
we're going to talk
to some people who have a personal
experience of
covid last winter and who lost
loved ones during that period first of
all
to jean adamson who lost her father
due to coronavirus gene thank you very
much indeed for joining us
i understand you've been listening to
those exchanges
in the house of commons what's your
response to them
yes i've been this new and i feel
very angry
it's it's just despicable absolutely
despicable the way this government has
behaved um over this
allegra stratton
um we are brief families
and whilst the rest of the nation
had to adhere to the rules
and we had to watch our loved ones dying
on their own
without a hand to hold
um without any comfort
um and
we have those who lead us
behaving in this way flouting
the rules that they make
again one rule for them
and another one for the rest of us
it's just absolutely safe
somewhat relatedly the prime minister
did apologize and say action will be
taken
if he can establish that the party did
go ahead
so do you blame the prime minister at
all
very
absolutely
uh firmly and squarely he is the prime
minister
the office which he holds
it carries that level of accountability
it's happened in his watch
and he has to be held accountable for
what happened
and down the street
whether he was there or not he's
accountable um he's now
uh promised to do an investigation um
and take this
reaction um if required um but why do
they always why does he always have to
be dragged
screaming and kicking
um before
he will
admit or tell the truth we need the
truth that's what we need we're tired of
his lies
you know the smoke and the mirrors um
you know we're sick of it
obfuscating the truth constantly it's
it's it's just you know there's a real
problem with integrity with this
government a real problem
please tell us a little bit about your
father and your experiences uh once he
went into hospital
my father
um
he contracted
in a care home
and died
um and this was during the first week
april last year
and my father was um
[Music]
he was 98 or 19 years old and died
but he was a very lively and
you know
i would say robust 98 year old
uh until
he contracted probably um and died
within two days
so um you know we're still
waiting for answers really around
how
you know our loved ones who died in
cairns contracted the virus there how
did how was it allowed to happen and
we're still waiting for answers we need
an explanation as to
why you know people have died in such
large numbers it's international
catastrophe you know
and
yes i mean it's it's it
compounds the grief and pain that we
feel because there are so many
unanswered questions and when you have
the government behaving in this way um
it just really intensifies you know the
pain and grief that we feel
you know we just feel as if we've been
treated with contempt
and and once you knew your father had
fallen now what contact were you able to
have with him
fortunately my father was on the ground
floor at the care home so
we were able to go and visit him and
speak to him through the window um but
um you know when he died he died alone
um
he was transferred to the hospital
so he died but you know he died alone
and really in the last few weeks
um
where i wasn't able to spend any time
you know with
him or have any you know tactile contact
with him it was you know it's very
clinical very impersonal you know
standing in the window talking to
someone
you know on their deathbed so it's
yeah
it's very
very helpful
gene addison thank you very much indeed
uh for joining us you have our
sympathies of course and uh apologies
for the quality of that but i think
of you as we want to hear from you
well joining us now is lobby akanola who
lost his uh 60 year old father to covid
also
in april last year
and mr akaner i think you were listening
to those exchanges in the house of
commons what's your response to them
um good afternoon thank you for having
me i think
seeing the comments in the uh prime
minister's questions today i was taken
aback um
by
the
prime minister on one hand saying that
he takes full responsibility for the
actions of his government and at the
same time
um this idea that
is paying politics to try and understand
why there is a party in turn downing
street and claiming that
there's a
no interest in the public
in in that party that could that has
been said to take place and that is
undermining the confidence of the
british public in um any
forthcoming restrictions um and i'd
argue that what undermines confidence is
having leadership that doesn't tell you
the truth
if there was a party
in downing street uh
last year
how does that make you feel about your
own experience with with your father
dying
it's
it's hard to put into words the
feeling of
um
just betrayal a sense of betrayal and
and hurt
because
um
before that first lockdown i had planned
to go home
um
you know talking to my family see you at
the weekend and then we went into
lockdown and it was this idea of well
it'll be a couple of weeks so you know
i'll come and see everyone but because i
stayed at
my house and followed the rules it meant
i never saw my father alive again
um the idea that the government can
know
the pain
that people are going through in this
country
and
ask for the sacrifice of not seeing
their loved ones whilst at the same time
going to parties themselves and joking
about
the fact that they're doing this is just
yeah a deep deep sense of betrayal
have you ever
supported this government in the past
um i wouldn't say that i've been a um
supporter of this government but
primarily i'd say that that's because
um
i've had questions personally about
uh integrity and
um
you know being able to trust the word of
this government and unfortunately i
haven't seen anything that would
uh convince me that these concerns were
misplaced you know
the prime ministers had
plenty opportunity to come forward or
even at the first instance when we first
raised coincidence as a nation about the
party taking place why didn't an
investigation start then why is it
starting now after there's been a lot of
media pressure to do something
what do you think should happen now on
the basis of what you know
um i personally think that
to begin with we need accountability
and for accountability to take place in
the count we need to know exactly what's
taking place in
the government and we need the honest
truth no more you know um equivocating
and using uh political language to
distract people and the prime minister
needs to acknowledge painless been
caused give a heartfelt genuine apology
and i think that as part of an apology
is action
so we need to see
um accountability for people who are
taking in these law breaking because
that they broke the law if these parties
took place and we need to see an inquiry
start because as far as i'm concerned
from what i can see we haven't learned
anything throughout this 18 months plus
of uh the covered 19 virus in the uk
and finally tell us a little about your
father
um my father was a very caring loving
man um he worked with people learning
difficulties he gave a lot of his work
time and his own spare time
to
to make sure they're okay um he's
definitely someone who believed in
putting his fellow man first
um and
it's his
his um
i guess
legacy and the
care that he's
given me that you know drives me to be
part of this campaign um i generally
believe that yeah he was one of the best
of us and i miss him clearly
thank you
beth rigby uh it's obviously a very
difficult situation for the government
but fighting it really
yeah but you heard from gene and lobby
there they talked about betrayal they
said it was despicable they talked about
a problem of integrity they talked about
accountability now the prime minister
there what did he cut do he came to the
commons he was armed within a statement
he was armed with an apology he said
that watching that video made him feel
furious he said he would have an
investigation
and that people had there been a party
which he said he was now determined to
get to the bottom of uh that there would
be sanctions and consequences
for his
members of staff for his team in a way
what was he trying to do he was trying
to buy time but i have to say
that the
exchanges between him and kirstama the
prime minister looked uncomfortable it
looked unconvincing his head was bowed
the most powerful part for me was when
kirsten talked about the queen and
talked about the leadership she showed
when her husband died and she sat alone
you remember in that funeral her husband
of 73 years
and kierstarmer looked at the prime
minister he said do you really think you
have the moral authority to lead and
this is now the question for the prime
minister isn't it his authority his
authority with the public and also his
authority on the benches uh with his
party where the mood was clearly
terrible in there also uh withering
comments about the justice secretary uh
from kierstama correcting him on the
fact that the police do uh investigate
things that happened a year ago
leading police johnson to say he will
hand over evidence yeah
yes i mean that could be a problem and
this so this is another interesting
development from this prime minister's
questions the prime minister said there
i will have an internal investigation
and i will report back and i will report
back to the commons now kierstarma who
we know used to be the head of the crown
prosecution service said well hang on a
minute what about an investigation
by the police it's not the case that
they do not investigate retrospective
crimes that is not true uh what dominic
the justice secretary said um and he
then put out a tweak his stammer after
pmq's saying the prime minister must
hand over everything the government
knows about the parties in downing
street to the police the prime minister
there at pmq's seem to agree
to do that so i think that is now a
clearly emerging
strand of this story
and allegations from ian blackford who
called for the prime minister to resign
that
there actually could have been three
parties and we also heard that from
a labour spokesman as well yeah the
other development that happened in prime
minister's questions where there were
two parties reported in the daily mirror
um
six days ago a week ago
and then dominic cummings the former
aide of uh the prime minister that we
all know very well following his um
his appearance at that select committee
where he talked about the government's
uh failings as he saw it over covered he
then put out a tweet in the middle of
prime minister's question suggesting
that there was also a party i'm just
trying to find it here it is will the
cabinet secretary also be asked to
investigate the flat party on friday the
13th of november the other flat parties
and the flats bubble policies so dominic
cummings there suggesting that there was
a party in the flat at downing street on
november the 13th so another uh series
of questions raised about the tweet of
dominic commons i think that must have
been as he was leaving downing street
beth rugby thank you very much indeed
also worth pointing out that the prime
minister more or less confirmed that
there will be
an announcement coming from the
government on further restrictions
so-called plan b in the face of the
omicron variant and challenged by a very
angry conservative backbencher he also
said the cabinet would be consulted on
this we'll have to see how that develops
as well but that is
all from us on sky news and all that
politics for today but do stay with us
an awful lot going on here in
westminster
[Music]
you